oh god oh no I asked artificial
intelligence to write me a delicious
recipe that's never been made before and
it came up with grilled chocolate
stuffed Marshmallow with strawberry
bacon relish first I inserted some
chocolate into a makeshift marshmallow
pocket then I cooked up some bacon bits
until they're nice and crispy and then
started making my strawberry relish I
personally have never had this recipe
before but I'm really curious to know if
you guys have I've had bacon and
chocolate and obviously chocolate
covered strawberries but never all of
these things combined I finally roasted
my marshmallows which surprisingly
didn't end up in a melted chocolate mess
and then added my relish and bacon and
tried it
not terrible
look I got all this bacon